sept à huit je pense qu'il est très
assidu il est très professionnel dans sa
démarche et je pense qu'il arrive à
prendre la compétition à la fois avec
sérieux à la fois avec légèreté
cela fait trois ans que ce coach sportif
blésois accompagne raphaël baud gillet
dans sa préparation physique
une préparation qui va s'intensifier
afin que mois des jo de tokyo
c'est quoi ta 6 7 6 je me dis qu'il est
à dire qu il va soulever environ 70 à
80% de ses charges maximum qui va
répéter entre 8 et 10 fois pour tout
simplement pour faire gonfler on va dire
un peu le raphaël a perdu la
quasi-totalité de la vue à 20 ans une
maladie génétique qui a bouleversé sa
vie sa revanche
il l'a prise sur un vélo enfin sur un
tandem ce tandem ils le partagent depuis
septembre avec françois perly septuple
champion du monde sur piste chez les
valides avec françois on est on est
toujours dans l'apprentissage de se
connaître
que ce soit sur le vélo et en dehors du
vélo parce que oui le tandem c'est c'est
comme un couple d'intrus doit rouler
normalement pour qu'on fasse qu'un voilà
on entendait même jour houleux
de mes yeux et
aussi séparé on doit pédaler en même
temps depuis dix ans raphaël bougies les
enchaîne les podiums
champion du monde en 2012 en duathlon il
a aussi décroché 25 titres de champion
de france après des années de
compétition sur route
raphaël s'est spécialisé dans la course
sur piste qui leur ont plus autonomes
notamment pour ses entraînements
avantages des efforts sur piste c'est
que j'ai pas besoin de faire de sortie
de deux trois heures
des fois j'ai un entraînement qui peut
durer une heure et demie parce que j'ai
des longues phases de récupération de 20
minutes je vais avoir 4 5 et fort dans
la séance
mais avec 20 minutes de récup du coup je
peux faire mes entraînements
pratiquement à 95% seule la prochaine
médaille qu'il vise est olympique et ce
sera à tokyo à partir du 22 août